[Music]  [Music]  you're after something  [Music]  is it revenge  [Music]  money  or is it something else you look good  little rough around the edges but good  heard about a job big shot gangster  putting together crew  I'm a driver and I'm a flier  I waited a long time for a shot like  this  what do you think well what do you know  you got a line on the ship  yeah no guy either by smuggler around I  heard a story about you I was wondering  if it's true everything you read about  me it's true l-3 let's go with a mean  man's face who are these guys  [Music]  if you come with us you're in this life  for good might wanna buckle up baby  [Music]  let me give you some advice assume  everyone will betray you  and you'll never be disappointed I got a  really good feeling about this  when do you know how to fly a hundred  and ninety years old feel great  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]